so this year
i have to think how is i going to roast
west
or as west might put it how am i going
to troll west
so i thought the best way to do that to
west this year
was to have him give a talk with an r
user who likes watching him get trolled
so
with that please welcome neil and wes to
the stage
[Music]
yeah we got our walk-on song here
gotta let it play out
all right all right nice shirt
you know i love it oh it's school
all right are we ready to go
hey everyone nice to uh nice to see see
you virtually
uh virtually here okay i see the uh
chrome tab is up so i'm gonna go ahead
and get
and get started um so this has been a
fun conference for me to speak at for
the last uh
last five years maybe it's been six
years it's hard i'm losing track of time
but uh it seems there's maybe an
alarming trend for people that my talks
seem to be increasingly about
r as time goes on so we will you know we
can extrapolate into the future and uh
and we'll see and maybe maybe i'll start
talking about julia
five years from now we will see what
happens um so we've been doing a lot of
work
on um on improving data access
and um in analytics performance uh
through the through the apache arrow
project and we'd like to share
with you kind of the background for for
this work and some of the results that
that
that we are seeing now uh using using
the aero stack from from r
so neil and i are leading leading ursa
labs
which we established in in partnership
with our studio two years ago
uh to to build more or less a strategic
industry consortium with
with companies that want to invest time
and money in the apache aero ecosystem
with the mission
of building a cross-language uh high
performance platform for data science
that is based on
uh that's based on the aero project
we've now grown the team to six
six full-time people and we have a lot
of great great sponsors so if you'd like
to learn more
uh check us out on ursalabs.org and we'd
love to have you involved in
um in ursa labs or in the aero project
in in some way
so the the thesis of what this all about
what this is all about and
how i got interested in arrow in the
first place is that
if you observe um what do our processors
spend a lot of time doing when we're
doing data analysis
so one thing is they spend a lot of time
converting between data formats you know
everyone is aware
that loading csv files loading parquet
files loading data from databases is one
of the most
you know tedious and time consuming time
consuming parts
of data analysis and where data
scientists spend a lot of time thinking
about how they
how they can reduce the amount of time
that they spend
loading data into memory in addition to
that
if we look at the algorithms and the
computational systems
that we use to do our data analysis our
analytical computing
so they've definitely lagged behind the
advances in hardware that have occurred
over the last
over the last 10 years when you consider
that now you can have a laptop with
eight cores or 16 cores
and 64 or 128 gigs of ram for you know
compare that versus
the hardware that was available 10 years
ago and so
the software that we're using hasn't
really kept up with
you know the the advances in in hardware
very much
um developers also spend a lot of time
uh building and maintaining
uh data connectors and you know what we
think of his glue code for for getting
data
into uh into the analysis environment
and even within a programming language
you might find
you know r has many um he has many
implementations of reading csv files the
same is true of python you know in
python we have multiple implementations
of reading
at least three that i can think of
implementations of reading parquet files
so there's a lot of developer energy
that is spent on the problem of loading
data
because it is so important to uh you
know to to the analysis so so the goal
of
you know why i've been working on the
aero project for almost five years now
and the mission of ursa labs and what
our team is doing is to make scalable
data processing
faster and simpler and more cost
effective so you getting more out of the
hardware that we already have
so the aero project which i've spoken
about at this conference
you know many times in re in recent
years
we've been working on for a little over
four years we just reached a major
milestone last month our 1.0 release
which
marks our very first stable release
even though the project has been
informally stable since the end of 2017
this is the first
uh the first release where we are
comfortable uh putting stable on the
documentation
and making it clear that we're not going
to make any backwards and compatible
changes
and additionally if we introduce new
features in the future which might
uh break old libraries that we are
checking
for um that we can detect uh features
coming from the future so that you know
if one library updates to a newer
version
that we can still read the data that it
produces
in older libraries um so from the data
science perspective the the function of
arrow is to provide
a portable cross-language foundation for
computational foundation for uh for data
processing
and it aims to synthesize the the
lessons that have been learned both
in the data science the data frame
library ecosystem libraries like pandas
dplyr data table and the analytic
database world so what you see
over the last 15 20 years of analytic
database development
and so it's one of the first really
productive collaborations that we've
seen between the database community and
the data science community
and it's designed specifically to be
able to get the most out of our modern
hardware so multi-core cpus gpus
and we're even seeing arrow used on
fpgas and other specialized
specialized hardware so arrow provides
among other things provides a columnar
format and one of the first things that
people say is well
i'm already using a columnar format our
data frames are columnar
column oriented pandas data frames are
column oriented
but it turns out that not all column
columnar formats are created equal
and so a lot of care has been taken with
arrow to how data is arranged
particularly with dealing with
non-numeric data
string data nested data so that we can
process that data very efficiently and
it can also be processed
at high performance with multi-core
architectures so it can be
you know if you have a gpu with 5000
cuda cores or a cpu with you know 20 you
know 16 or 20
20 cores um that we get you know
effectively linear scalability on
processing our tabular data
the project has grown to with to include
currently 11 different
programming languages in the project
there are six different
uh native implementations of arrow and a
collection of bindings to the various
native
native implementations our team has been
primarily focused on the c
plus library and the bindings in in
python and r
the community has been growing very fast
so we recently crossed the 500
unique contributor threshold and i think
particularly
given that arrow just reached 1.0 that
the the developer community around it
will continue to grow
at a rapid rate so i will
uh with that said i will turn uh turn
turn things over to uh to neil to talk
about the r package and to
take a deeper dive into what we've been
doing for the r ecosystem
awesome thanks so um
let me make that bigger
cool so uh the our package for arrow is
on crayon
um and uh so you can just install
packages to get it
um some of the things i'm going to talk
about are available in the 1.0 release
some of things i'm going to talk about
uh and demonstrate are
uh not yet in the 1.0 release but you
can check them out
on our nightly development builds if you
have the aero package you can just
install call the install arrow function
to
to get them
so it feels like many many years ago but
it's actually just a little over
six months ago i did a demo of
the state of the era package uh at the
time
uh where i read a multi-file uh par k
data set with 125 parquet
files new york city taxi data over 10
years um
and you know i did this uh
our this you know query of filtering and
selecting and doing grouping and
aggregating
and uh you know so scanning over almost
two billion rows and getting a result
in four seconds and uh that was awesome
that was super fast we were really
excited about that people seem to be
excited about that
um i ran the same query uh
this past week just uh with the latest
version of arrow just to see
how we were doing kind of an informal uh
benchmark
and thanks to the work that wes knows in
the community have been doing
in the c plus library uh it's now over
twice as fast today
to do the exact same work which is
really exciting so if we were going
light speed
before we are now finding ways to go
beyond light speed
and into ludicrous speed um there's
a lot of uh excitement uh of people that
took me after the conference
but a common reaction was that's really
cool but i don't have parking files
what can you do for me and at the time i
was like well
i'll find a way to get parquet files but
i have a better answer now
uh so this is available in the 1.0
release
you can now read data multi-file data
sets that are based on csvs
so to demonstrate i took just uh six
months of the taxi data and wrote it
into csv i didn't want to fill my hard
drive up with it completely
but just to illustrate and so i can just
point at that directory just as easily
as i can
with parquet files and um
and i can do you know a similar type of
filter
and select and uh group by and aggregate
query and
you know it's dealing with a little bit
less data and it's not as fast as
kind of west's point about serialization
even though we're doing we're
deserializing and
parsing efficiently it still is not as
fast as if you're in an efficient
columnar format
so you might think well how can i get my
cacs into a more efficient columnar
format
in uh the the stuff we've been working
on recently
in our the latest nightly builds you
should be able to write a data set to
feather formats so take a multi-file
whatever data set and write a bunch of
feather files
hopefully next week we'll be adding
parquet to that so the idea is i've got
my data set that i already created here
and i can i can
add this group by to that and in this
context what group by is saying
is i want to partition my data set
by this column this is one of the
variables that i
did my filter on maybe i think this is
an interesting thing that i often
am filtering on so if i partition by it
it's going to speed up
my ability to query this and what that
means is when i write the data set
i'm going to get a bunch of
subdirectories that are split out we
have the data split out by the value of
that
that payment type variable so
i can then read that i can load this
feather data set now and do the exact
same query
and uh thanks to the fact that i'm
taking advantage of partitioning but
also
the feather format is the arrow in
memory format so there is literally
zero uh serial deserialization to deal
with it's just
the same thing as it is in memory uh
now um i get the same result but a
hundred times faster so
um so if we were going lunar crispy
before maybe we can
go go plaid go even beyond ludicrous
speed
so uh we talked a little bit about csvs
um
it's a kind of the nature of the
business that you have to deal with csvs
and it's definitely not the most
efficient format
in many ways
one of the challenges that we in dealing
with is just reading into memory and the
speed of doing that
and of course there are many csv readers
anyone have an idea as to what the
fastest one in r
is is it the base read.csv function
does it get faster if you had an
underscore i'm sure there's somebody out
there that's screaming why hasn't he
said data table yet
um is it vroom vroom's super cool uh
those really great things with reading
csvs
or is it arrow's csv reading function
you might think it is since
that's your what i'm here to talk about
uh it turns out this is a trick question
because it depends on a lot of things
particularly when you're talking about
reading a csv
um you know your system uh features
matter
you know you might not have uh 5000 uh
cuda cores to on a gpu to read things
like wes does
um and so i could say that something's
fastest on my machine and you might find
something faster on your machine
also really important particularly with
parsing data files like this is the
shape of the data some
readers are better can better handle
certain sizes of data or shapes whether
it's
very many columns wide or lots of rows
or long
data types uh you know whether it's
strings or floating points or whatever
like these can all
different libraries have optimized for
different things
and so there's not generally an absolute
fastest
that said we can still we can still try
to make uh
make some sort of statement about uh
speed relative
across libraries so the only way we do
it is with benchmarking and benchmarking
you think of like as being like a
scientific experiment we're going to try
to hold as many of those variables
constant
so that except for the code that we're
running
to get our result and then we can
conclude that
at least within assuming those variables
the differences we're seeing is because
of
the code like a good experiment a good
benchmark
is explicit as to what you're holding
constant and what you're varying
and it's also reproducible
even so as with an experiment you have
this concern of external validity so
i can run something with on a certain
set of hardware
and with a certain data set and i might
be able to definitively say that under
those conditions
one is faster than the other but it
doesn't mean that that's going to be
globally true for all data sets and all
hardware so your mileage
will vary is an important caveat
so everything i'm about to show you and
in terms of numbers i'm going to show
you i will
of course say your mileage may vary
um vroom which i mentioned a second ago
is really awesome and um there's so many
things that i love about it
one of the things that i i love about it
today
is its benchmark suite it has this
vignette
that compares vroom to radar and
data table and the base read csv and
arena limb
and um and it compares against uh
multiple data files and kinds of data
including real data not just simulated
data that's a common
problem i think with benchmarks is that
you you're benchmarking something that's
not a real
real world scenario um and it does some
real work with it
part of the reason why vroom is fast is
because it defers the parsing
of the csv and so in order to
really compare head to head you have to
do some work with the
the data set because that's when you
actually pay for parsing it is when you
deal with it due to alt rep and some
other cool things it's got going there
this benchmark is is very uh this
report is really uh interesting in that
um
it's all very uh well documented and
scripted so you could
you could run it on your machine or uh
you could also
extend it by adding some more scripts so
that's what i did
i took rooms benchmarks and i added a
couple of variations so the first one
is just using the arrow csv reading
function and returning a data frame
and then where you can use data table or
dpi or whatever on top of that
the second version that i did
takes the arrow read csv function but
keeps the data in the arrow table format
doesn't bring it into r and does the
computation using the arrow
compute library on top of that which
takes advantage of some of those
features that wes was talking about
and finally um there's a number of other
of packages in the python ecosystem
that use arrow with some very
interesting results and there's a whole
project out of nvidia called rapids that
is a bunch of gpu
libraries they have a data frame library
called qdf
and uh so i called that from r
using reticulate and could and thanks to
some features in the error
package can pull results uh from qdf
off of the gpu into my r session
uh i've so i took the uh vroom benchmark
added these things to it and then i
published the report there the link is
there
should also say in case you missed it
the link to these slides is at the
bottom of every slide
and i tweeted it right before the talk
so uh if i'm if i if you've missed
something i want to go back it's there
i did use wes's very beefy nvidia
workstation that nvidia
donated to ursa labs to do this the
reason being
i wanted to test the gpu work and i
needed a machine with a nice gpu on it
so like i said there are a few different
data sets and
and things that it does it does this
basic workflow on all of them so you
know
it does the read csv but then it also
filters some rows does a group
aggregation
and stuff like that uh okay so
uh really quickly i want to show a
couple results if you want to look at
more again
the full set is on the is on my website
there
so the first uh benchmark in the suite
is
uh uses the a month of new york city
taxi data our favorite data set
uh 15 million rows as a csv
and so here's the results here uh
there's a lot of bars here so what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to i'm
going to gray out the ones that
are part of the core benchmark and just
focus on the
four that i added so that's arrow
reading
reading with arrow and then doing the
work with dplyr
reading arrow and then doing the
aggregation and stuff with data table
and then qdf on its own and then the
last one the fastest one down there at
the bottom
is the version using arrow and doing the
computation in arrow as you can see that
one comes out
to be fastest on this machine with this
beta
beating out uh broom and data table and
the rest there
and um interestingly the you can see
that the last bar there the last
segment of the tan one that says
aggregate that actually is the biggest
one
for the arrow version at the bottom and
that's because
we haven't implemented all of the
grouped aggregation uh stuff
in arrow yet so in order to do that
calculation it's actually pulling the
data into
r but even with that
uh all of the other work leading up to
that is still we're still feeding r very
quickly
um qdf in terms of the actual the
reading of the csv wasn't as fast but
the aggregations on it were super fast
100 milliseconds going over 15 15
million rows that was pretty cool to see
one other thing i wanted to point out
here is that these green bars
just show the time to read
uh an r data frame so the ones that are
all grayed out
completely don't actually yield a data
frame at the
end of the read csv command but these do
and what's interesting here is that even
just using arrow to read the csv and
getting a data frame
that's significantly faster on this data
set more than 10 seconds faster
than data table f read uh or all rep uh
i'm sorry vroom with without all rep
and um and so you could even just use
the arrow csv reader and then
not do anything else with arrow and you
can still get some significant speed ups
um really quickly just a couple of other
points you can see more of this in the
report
um i know i don't have the the slides
here but you can see them there
uh it and some of these other uh
variations
in the um in the vroom report
you can see the arrow really shines with
text data as
wes is pointing out the arrow's strength
in the format
in terms of non-numeric data and you
really see that when you're reading in a
bunch of big strings
r is not as efficient at that finally
uh the last benchmark that i'll show uh
there's also a multi-file uh taxi
data set example in the room benchmarks
using 12 months of taxi visa at csv
and i think this one's really
interesting so arrow's not the fastest
here
overall it's really fast at a lot of
things the aggregation the the reading
stuff is really fast
but there's this big one in the middle
that doesn't really register with the
other ones and that's the sampling
method
and that's because we haven't written a
give me 100 random rows from this data
set
method yet in arrow so i did something
kind of naive in r
just just so i could complete the
workflow here and illustrate that
and i think the point here is it's it
really showcases
the two things that i want you to take
away from this first is that
what eric can't do everything yet but
the things that it does do now
is really fast and can really help you
today so reading the csv itself
particularly when you have millions of
rows or lots of strings
that stuff is really fast now and it's
well implemented in arrow
but we haven't gotten everything yet but
i hope that gives you a sense that
uh the direction we're going and that um
when those things start to come online
and arrow you're going to continue to
see those
speed ups for you know that just happen
month on month
so we will hopefully in the future we
will go plaid thanks a lot everybody
thank you very much i just want to
remind weston neil to pop over to be
interviewed i love the spaceballs
references that was really well done
neil
much better than anything west did in
there i'm sorry i just had to give west
a little bit of trolling west you're
awesome too
but i seem to troll west a little bit
because that though as i say it's our
thing at least it's my thing
um and unfortunately i haven't seen you
in a long time so i haven't been able to
sneak our stickers onto your book bag or
your luggage or anything
hopefully you'll get to see everybody in
person soon